transport secretary's here grant chaps
it's sensational to have you in the
studio okay lovely to be here yeah i'm
coming to an end
you didn't bring a red box with you um
talk to me first of all about the great
news about transport and travel yeah so
really pleased to say it's been a long
time in coming when you go abroad there
are no more tests to take when you come
home so you don't need to take a test
before you leave wherever you're coming
from to get here you don't need to take
a day two the day eights are already
gone you can just come home and the only
thing we ask you to do is fill in a
passenger locator form which we are
going to simplify by the way that would
be good yes
ridiculously complicated to work your
way through so you'll fill in one of
those uh passenger locator forms that's
it no quarantine no testing and all that
cost will drop away
sensational from the 11th of february i
think 11th of february in time for the
half term break and a couple of other
small things including um children 12 to
15 being able to use the nhs covet app
to demonstrate uh that they've been
vaccinated that's where countries
require that and uh all under 18's uh
exempt anyway so it's going to be a on
the way back so it's going to be a big
change much cheaper and i'm really
delighted nobody wants to be going to
ukraine at the moment though do the u.s
troops um are on high alert what should
the uk be doing well the prime minister
met with uh biden several european
leaders last night um we've made it very
very clear to president putin that there
will be severe consequences uh if he
crosses that border
well uh i i don't want to go into too
much detail but economic and economic
response would be very strong but
britain's also
sent
defense
weapons and training to the ukraine's
ukrainians in order to assist with uh
protecting the country could there be a
military response well that that is
already uh partially a a military
response and look i think the important
thing is that president putin should be
under no doubt at all that the
international coalition is there and
very tightly coordinating which is why
that meeting yesterday was so important
to
to make sure that this will not be would
not be cost cost-free and he should not
do it can you envisage a scenario where
there are british troops on the ground
in ukraine uh well there are already
british troops in support or or military
support to the ukrainians with some
defensive weapons so that is already the
case i don't want to go into too much
detail but i think you know what i mean
but but what i will but what i will say
is ukraine is a independent sovereign
nation uh that sovereignty should be
expected respected in total in total
including crimea it would be completely
unacceptable for him to cross the border
and there will be a very strong and very
coordinated response if he does okay
you're a father aren't you um i want to
show you this letter from josephine
seven-year-old josephine wrote to the
prime minister
and she was praised by the prime
minister um because she had said that
she wasn't going to have a party because
she wanted to abide by the rules um
thoughts on that given what happened
yeah no i i've seen that letters
and it's lovely and as you say i'm a dad
and i wasn't able to see my dad who was
in hospital for four months so i
understand the sense of concern uh about
the sort of reports we see on the on the
front of the uh newspapers it obviously
was the prime minister's
birthday he'd been given a cake earlier
in the day that's the picture in on the
newspapers and he was clearly given a a
cake by his staff when he got back to
the office these are staff he would have
been working with and was working with
all day long
and will have been many of times in the
same room with them uh working on the
response to coronavirus they come in
give him a cake i understand anything
lasted for 10 minutes uh and that was it
uh 11th of june let's just let's just
unplug it then should we 11th of june
which was eight days before the event in
the cabinet room this is what he said in
downing street
we relax the rules on meeting outdoors
so that groups of up to six could gather
provided they are socially distant
but you couldn't gather inside yes
i should just point out that uh that
picture's obviously from earlier in the
day when he when he was that's all right
then the school um outside i should
point out the uh
work response is people working in uh
essential areas and obviously including
the response to coronavirus in in in
downing street were already working
together so there wasn't a gathering of
people who weren't already
working in the same building he would
have been in the cabinet room as it
turns out in this case many many many
times with those people working
on the response socially distance uh uh
you know
they brought in
okay well family
because the unusual thing about downing
street is both a home and a and an
office and family members can always
could always throughout this environment
his interior designer was there
again she says that she wasn't invited
to uh any any parties so you know she
was there she was in the building of
course and
she said she was told that she was going
to have a meeting with the prime
minister in the middle of the day
when he was navigating a global pandemic
you've got to be kidding me well look i
wasn't there but all i can
transport secretary
and still you can keep a straight face
well look at kate as you know mistakes
were made and the prime minister said
that you know yourself mistakes were
made during coronavirus sometimes people
would regret the things that they uh did
um this was a period of slightly more
relaxed uh
rules well the prime minister's already
said that he apologizes for any mistakes
that were made i do understand i was
going to say i understand that sugree
was already aware of this uh particular
uh incident and so she will be using
that in her report and we'll wait to see
what she says rishi sunet was there
well look again everyone who works in uh
the building will have been in meetings
constantly with the prime minister
including rishi sunak including the
prime minister and his his staff
just be clear the prime minister clearly
didn't organize to be given a cake some
people came forward and thought it would
be appropriate for on his birthday
at the time let's just look at the rules
at the time then shall we this is what
the rules were saying at the time can we
quit look at those here we go
no person may participate in a gathering
which takes place in a public or private
place outdoors and consists of more than
six people indoors and consists of more
than two persons yes
people working together were in in
essential areas were obviously working
together so you you can't you you know
an office building yes that's right but
an office building uh already required
people to work together so the cabinet
room was an office building
well it isn't yeah so i was the interior
designer in it well she was working
in the building and this was at a period
uh when the she come next door down
three flights of stairs well look
she already said that she wasn't invited
to the event but look you're bigger your
bigger point but she had a meeting i
don't know she had a meeting why would
they with the wider let's unpack that
why would an interior designer that was
doing a flat come down three flights of
stairs go next door and go in to see a
prime minister who was trying to
navigate a global pandemic you're asking
me questions i can't provide the answer
to because i wasn't there
however fortunately i mean it looks as
though it's against the rules to me
unfortunately i was gonna say
fortunately um sue gray who's already
aware of this will be able to get to the
bottom of that which i think is actually
the right way to do it okay look at i
understand the sense of frustration i
say to you i could not see my own dad
who we didn't think we were going to see
again when he went into hospital he then
remained there for four months i feel
personally very upset when i see
stories about
you know lockdowns being broken in in
any form and many people have found that
they cross the wrong side of that line
at different times
i understand that uh it upsets uh it
upsets me well the prime minister's
already already said that he takes full
responsibility for everything that
happens in in downing street and saying
in this case
this is what he said i was going to say
just i said let me just tell you this
this is what he said on the 8th of
december to the house of commons
i can understand
how infuriating it must be to think that
the people who have been setting the
rules have not been following the rules
mr speaker because i
was also furious to see that clip
i have been
repeatedly assured since these
allegations emerged that there was no
party
and that
and that no kovid rules were broken
well as i say he didn't organize a party
uh someone presents a cake to him and
singing
happy birthday mr prime minister happy
birthday to you
it was his birthday and these are people
that he work with all the time as i said
i don't seek to
uh defend it this is for sue gray to
decide on uh whether this was
appropriate she'll make the
recommendations i think we can be pretty
clear the prime minister didn't present
a cake to himself this is somebody
coming in
with that cake and i've explained to you
that i'm furious with everybody but
you're not defending it are you but
because i'm furious with everybody who
broke the rules and a lot of different
people will have found that you know
perhaps unwittingly the trangress
transgressed the the the rules during
the period of lockdowns that is a fact
uh it's quite right that um that's
investigated the prime minister
apologizes if uh and where uh he has uh
transgressed uh and uh you know uh these
are people who with whom he would have
been in the room many many times
probably that day as well uh for a
series of meetings
with the coronavirus response the fact
that it's his birthday and they then say
oh and here's a cake i don't think
changed the fact that he was in the room
with them in any case for other matters
how often do people gather in the
cabinet room when they're not cabinet
secretaries oh that room's used as a
meeting room all the time particularly
was during corona virus that's not cake
i was going to say because there's a
back door that can be open so you get a
flow of air it's a larger room so you
could meet socially distance so it would
have been used constantly throughout
corona virus including a few days before
when the prime minister came in with
rishi sunak and and paid his respects to
the loss of life on the front line with
the frontline workers there he is very
somber indeed and as you can see two
days later he was it doesn't matter he
was breaking the rules everybody in that
room about 30 people um were breaking
the rules and thus breaking so let me
just put the question to you if i may
breaking the rules and thus breaking the
law should they all be issued with a
fixed penalty notice so first of all the
should they so could let me just answer
your question first of all the
circumstances are disputed so i
understand that number 10 are saying
that there was nowhere near 30 people
i'm not there sue gray will be able to
answer that and that's what she'll do um
secondly there will have been many
occasions when exactly the same staff
were meeting in that room because you
could be socially distanced the door uh
opens uh and these are people that the
prime minister will have been working
with all of the time so the difference
here is that a cake was entered into
brought into the singing which was also
against the rules at the time yeah and
again sue gray will have to report back
on that and look as i say uh and the
interior designer was that uh as i say
she'll have to report back on all the
facts i know that the interior designer
she wasn't
and sue grey will have to answer the
questions i wasn't i wasn't there okay i
i wasn't invited so you're asking me to
respond no all i'm asking no i'm not i'm
saying it's quite i'm giving you the
facts that we know that there were more
people there than were allowed to be
there at the time thus breaking the
rules thus breaking the law so should
they all get a fixed penalty
so so i think i'm right in saying that
in uh the working uh environment when
people were uh in downing street they
would have been together these the same
group of people would have been together
many many times they would have been
from here's uh from his office they
would have been working together they
probably met in there earlier that day
or other days i imagine to discuss the
coronavirus response the big differences
here that someone presented a a cake as
you say
look i i
we can go around in circles but the only
thing that i think the rules i
acknowledge that it's upsetting for me
personally not being able to see my
father whenever i hear transgressions
from the rules okay okay i can see where
you're going with that however um as far
as fixed penalty notices are concerned
uh people got fixed penalty notices for
breaking the rules do you think they
should i think first of all we should
get to the facts and that's what sue
grey
will do i understand she was already
aware of this so this is not new to her
or her report so she will have been
already discussing the circumstances in
the kind of detail that you've you've
quizzed me on i'm afraid i don't have
the answers to but you did say you were
furious with anybody that broke the
rules are you would you be furious with
the prime minister if it proves it's
proven that he broke them well look the
prime minister was clearly presented
with the cake he's already said with
regard to that outside uh gathering on
the 20th i think it was uh that in
retrospect
you're talking about he should have gone
out there and said
away indoors singing cake 30 people
maybe a few no i think maybe some fewer
than that
his interior designer was there look
again we've got to love a plot we are we
are you're doing a very very good job of
you're doing a very very good job of
going around around in circles and the
only thing
is helpfully tell you because you're
asking me things beyond my
sphere of knowledge and that's why sue
gray is looking into it and she will be
able to give us the full background what
i don't really think is uh is is right
you get the sort of drip drip of of uh
reports in the media let's get the facts
and i don't think we'll have to wait
very long and then we'll all be able to
see what the facts were and as always
happens with these things it will turn
out that perhaps some of the stories
were uh written in a way which were you
know was designed to look in a certain
way this the the prime minister who you
know months earlier had been very close
to to death from um from covid was lucky
to come out of hospital he's working
incredibly hard and being out on a visit
and presented with a cake earlier in the
day comes back to his office where he's
working with the same bunch of people
he's working with all the time and they
decided to give him a cake for his
birthday now sue gray will tell us uh
the the rights and wrongs of that and
i'm happy to wait for her to i'm
guessing come 11th of february won't
have any restrictions if he wants to go
on holiday well everyone will be able to
get away at last that's true and do so
without all the cost when they come home
more than well thank you very much